well you have to do it you have to you
can't just be off for six months and
then step on a stage and expect to be
sort of in complete possession of your
vocal powers so it's a muscle like
anything else and you have to practice
and you have to just do it and that's
what keeps you I think going strong
I can tell you a terrible story well not
a terrible story but a true story
it's dreadful when you think about it
though it was back in the early 90s I
was touring in Australia with Lucinda
Williams and rosanne Cash and we were
doing these songwriter nights all around
Australia and every night we and we just
often share the same big dressing room
or whatever and every night Roseanne and
and Lucinda would warm up vocally and I
I had quite gotten to that place where I
realized that how important that was you
know and Roseanne would be in her corner
singing scales and and doing that sort
of thing and Lucinda had some method in
her corner just I think she would sort
of almost bend over and try to breathe
out and stuff and people would sort of
wonder what I would do and I sit in my
corner smoking a cigarette that's
terrible I don't smoke anymore
quit that a long time ago but that's
that's how naive I was about how
important it is to take care of your
voice
I know that a lot of I know a lot of
artists who smoke say that and swear by
it and but for me no I had to I had to
quit a long time ago